islam net is raising funds to establish
a masjid and community center in norway
every person who prays there every kid
that learns about islam every youngster
that memorizes the quran all of this and
so much more can be on your scale of
good deeds click the link and donate
what you can
[Music]
dear friends
if i was to say these two saudi women
that i'm about to show have literally
lost their minds i don't think you would
really blame me
saudi arabia or the arabian peninsula
when islam came it was full with filthy
the most filthy thing on this earth
which is out of worship
shirks and mushriks
alhamdulillah islam came and abolished
that
and one of the signs of the judgment is
that um
[Music]
the region
the arabian peninsula will go back into
idol worship but obviously shaytan takes
his time that's the end goal
and but today we're going to be watching
a video i'm reacting to
called like heaven
saudis enjoy sun sea with opposite sex
let's watch this video and let's see if
we can hold our stomachs and not be sick
here it goes
all our welcome at the saudi beach
yeah
in a change to the usual gender gender
segregation and what is clothing
this speech in gender allows men and
women to mingle
now let's really let's listen let's
listen carefully to this girl yeah but
she makes me cringe she makes me sick to
my stomach like miami jab says yeah she
makes me sick she makes me sick look at
this listen very carefully here raised
here and a few years ago we weren't even
allowed to listen to music so this this
is like this is like a heaven this is
like uh i don't know i can't even
explain it to you you can't imagine it i
swear
i mean that really sums it up you know
it reminds me of the hadith of the
prophet salallahu sallam who told us
that when allah created heaven and hell
and he told angel gabriel from what i
remember
is that he sent he sent him to hell
and when angel gabriel saw hell he came
back he said oh allah i don't know of
any creation except that they would run
away from that
they'll run away from the hell then
allah said to the angel
go and look at jannah and when he looked
at janna and came back he said by allah
but i swear by you that there is no one
that that would run to it
yeah i'm paraphrasing it would would
want to be there
then allah sends him back to hell and
this goes exactly with what this woman
says
when he goes back and he sees allah
adorned it with temptations and all
these kind of things he said by allah i
do know i do not know anyone except that
they will enter it
they're going to be tempted by it
and when the angel came back i also
panicked i said go to heaven and when he
saw it with tribulations and trials he
said i do not know anyone except
that
they would like not enter it or
something along those lines the point
here is now when she says this this
um girl may allah guide her and guide us
that she's making it seem like this is
like heaven
that's heaven that's heaven why because
of a few moments of uh a moment of uh
ecstasy you know not literal drugs and
either the moment of you know a dopamine
rush yeah
having intimacy with the opposite
partner yeah with the opposite zinna
you're carrying stds don't know who
you're kissing who you're with drinking
alcohol yeah doing all these filthy
stuff you're in a place where you're
getting touched up left right center you
don't know who's touching you you're
like tomatoes in the shop yeah like it
nor throw it no this one i don't like it
let me touch you a bit here you go yeah
like a sexual object that's what you are
and you are proud of that and you live
in that kingdom subhanallah this shows
us mother says it doesn't matter where
you live
iman allah's guidance will come to those
who believe
he wants to believe
look at her and how she's glorifying
like she's gassed and happy like someone
promised the jannah or something oh this
is like heaven we used to listen to
music all this like heaven
wallahi
these kind of women have lost a plot and
men and men both of them but it just
makes me sick to my stomach to hear a
woman a muslim a woman from what we know
she's a muslim yeah growing up in those
lands
growing up on those lands and she's
dying and craving to this we live that
lifestyle we live the music and the
clubs we lived all this jahil lifestyle
well life is nothing but filth
oxton billah rivers like myself and many
you have lived that it is nothing but
dirt filth while
it's full of filth i've lived that
lifestyle
yeah it makes me sick to my stomach that
i i even live that yeah allah makes me
sick to my stomach
we ask allah subhanahu wa to protect us
and wallahi it shows you that the
direction that they're going in
is not a good direction and we ask allah
to protect us and keep us firm on the
saratov
till next time assalamu alaikum
and make this dua like the prophet
sallam said oh turn off the hearts
yeah all turn off the heart so allah
subhanahu wa tala thomson turns it with
his uh fingers away because his majesty
yeah
keep our hearts firm on your religion
till next
warahmatullahi
time